[Music]
look
some players in esports just have all
the luck
some players win majors world
championships you name it
but some players just don't today we
wanted to pay our respects to the
greatest players in esports who just
seemed cursed the unbelievably talented
competitors
who just can't seem to win anything but
before we get into that
i want to make sure you guys are
subscribed to the channel if you haven't
done so already
that way you'll never miss a video just
like this one and with that
let's get into the top 10 cursed players
in
esports
kicking off our list is the sickest
sneaky beakiest aimbot in the history of
cs go
scream the one for sure
yeah he's got one bullet in it he's
three legs got one bullet oh
scream just scream things that was on
purpose
now unfortunately scream is also one of
the
unluckiest csgo players of all time
scream only ever won four premier events
in his entire cs go career
which is insane given just how good he
is thanks to repeated kicks and one of
his teammates receiving
the most famous vac ban ever scream
never really saw the kind of success his
remarkable talent
seemed guaranteed to secure what would
you like to achieve in cs go before
you'd be happy retiring
i think i would i would like to hear the
gym before we die
since transitioning to valerian however
he's gained new life and has inspired a
whole new generation of gamers to talk
about his
well you know
[Music]
taking the ninth spot on our list is a
cracked counter-strike player who has
been
cursed by karma care by now once upon a
time kirby was a 17 year old danish
prodigy who'd spearheaded astralis to
their first ever major victory
snacks in an uncomfortable position he
goes down with the max 7 he can't make
it happen finally pasha coming in
with a refract but he's down the bomb
has been picked up by dupreeh they get
the spray kneel takes one and how's it
there
and astral as they win the first major
championship
16-14 against fluttershy and then
after becoming one of his game's
youngest major
mvps ever his roster results began to
taper off and
he well left but in all honesty we would
just
have appreciated a conversation about it
because also still at the moment we
really don't know why
he left the crazy thing is that as soon
as he left astralis in the lurch
his career went off a cliff for years he
watched his danish compatriots solidify
themselves as the greatest of all time
while he put up subpar performances on
north and
eventually faze clan now he's vying for
glory once again on the unsigned hyenas
and i
think i speak for all of us when i say i
hope
he finds it i really do
picture this you're on that point you're
one win away from becoming your region's
first ever major finalist
and you think what could possibly go
wrong
then out of nowhere this happens here he
comes once again the first base
is a trend he's gonna hit the ground
there's cold oh wow that's jumping
double
cold what is it going on right now how
does he do this
for our eight spot we're talking about
not only one of the most beloved boomers
in esports but i think it's fair to say
the most unreasonably unfortunate hiko
now the thing is for a clutch master he
has
a lot of trouble closing it out from
getting screwed out of a contract
he put together on account of the i buy
power match fixing scandal
to getting cold zero jumping off out of
a major final
hiko has literally spent almost a decade
trying to hit it big
the spray comes in the flames are making
it difficult but what can hiko do
he's got ethernet jumping through the
smoke and adren needs a one
versus four retake with an awp
and there it is cold he's gonna take his
head off and luminosity
will find themselves in the grand finals
against navi
i mean even after winning first strike
his valor and roster 100 thieves still
failed to qualify for the game's first
international
lan in iceland so it's just victor with
two curve balls
and six hp on nitro the feet won't work
victor takes it
and that's an easy defusal envy will
take the series
and they keep their chances alive in the
finals
still at 31 heco continues to be cracked
as hell
and crazy as it is to say his future is
still
very bright time to shed a tear now for
the unsung
goat of summoners rift cuz for our
seventh spot we're paying our respects
to uzi trades in the backlines
everyone's slow
everyone from ig is just gonna get taken
down triple kill being picked up by uzi
chasing down the four quarter duke's the
only one left alone
boasting some of the greatest raw
mechanical talent league of legends has
ever seen chinese superstar uzi spent
years asserting dominance over every a.d
carry and their mum without ever
actually winning a regional title
never mind an international one they're
gonna focus in
on the nectars itself and samsung white
for the 2040
world champions
and even though he did go on to secure
his first international victory at msi
2018
uzi never managed to lift the
ever-coveted summoners cup at worlds
plagued by injuries he retired midway
through 2020
leaving a legacy as one of his game's
greatest to never win the big one
all right for our number six contender
we're pouring one out for simple it's
going to be a clean sweeping
look to things i think we could have
done it it's a five versus one
and there it is team liquid are going to
the grand finals
what a performance what a comeback and
they've done it once again
commonly regarded as the greatest cs go
player to ever live
simple has achieved just about
everything there is to do
in counter-strike he's been an hl tv
number one
won a cologne an iem katowice and racked
up
countless mvp medals to put it simply
he's a god watch it because he's got the
lineup simple he doesn't have the time
he's got to go to the ak get the kill
this guy is on another level he's gonna
have time to put the ball down
and x7 he knows he's in rotation to
flash out he's got the information
he's got just enough he goes back to the
awp but is that what's gonna cost
and it's gonna cost him
despite playing in two major finals on
two separate teams
simple has never managed to actually win
one
whether he ever will well that remains
to be seen
one thing is for sure though if anyone
has the ability to take on the world and
win it's simple for the halfway point
on our list now we're heading off to
halo that's right
you heard me one of the most genuinely
cursed competitors in esports is one of
master chief's greatest disciples
needed to help and i will not miss a
shot i will
whoever i see is gonna die nated is not
gonna miss a shot
whoever he sees is gonna die i can't
wait to see you play buddy
despite racking up a staggering number
of high placements over the course of
his 12-year career
native somehow never managed to secure
the top spot at a major
4v4 event and though he may have retired
in 2018
his legacy lives on as a streamer and
beloved community figure
few have hustled as hard or done as much
for halo esports as
naded who in addition to being the
longest tenured halo professional
ever remains one of its most successful
eeking his way into the top four is
north america's
greatest street fighter hope punk one of
the strongest players and
of course you see a nod of approval
there oh a little sassiness a little gum
shoe
so the thing with punk unfortunately is
that despite pretty much
always being touted as one of the best
players in the world
and the favorite at any tournament he
attends when it comes time to show it
off
the dude simply cannot bring it home on
the biggest stages the game has to offer
to go either direction is it going to be
a stun very close
he hit a button he's so genius the taunt
he did a talk about a bunk a grand
finals of
evil i've never seen him do anything
like that
from evo finals to capcom cups to pro
tours
punk has solidified himself as a kind of
second place machine when it comes to
world championships
he's getting the crotch immediately
oh my god i don't believe it
for the first time this weekend
thankfully like any great competitor out
there he keeps his spirits up and
remains graceful in defeat
showing us all that one day he'll
hopefully have what it takes to
finally go all the way
securing himself the bronze medal for
our list is an orpha who needs
no introduction guardian
oh this is a done round guardian now is
the question as to whether he'll save
the awp
good flashbang could get a couple more
out of this one
are starting to crumble what's going on
one
player has found three kills guardian
looking to ace this one out this could
be one of the best rounds
of the entire tournament so far four
kills picked out
guardian knows exactly where to look
he's got
all five a slovakian superstar whose
very name has inspired fear and loathing
in adversaries across the globe
few players have secured legacies as
untouchable
as that of guardians the guardian is
also
by pretty much everyone's estimation the
one competitor whose inability to secure
a major title
is just downright tragic we saw from
this position before
he cannot miss a single shot
guardian weights patiently as cloud9
sets the push up
oh oh this happens they made it work
a three-time major finalist guardian
secured second place finishes at cluj
napoca
columbus and boston before returning to
navi
and after suffering a steep drop off in
performance
getting benched as for whether he'll
ever etch his name onto the one
trophy he doesn't have and which he is
all too deserving of
well that remains to be seen what we do
know
is that he isn't ready to give up just
yet
taking the close but no cigar spot on
our list is
ironically league of legends single most
untitled
all-star of all time jovi still fighting
by the way
able to get that double kill and i think
maybe
the ruse was a bit
so here's the thing we all know that
shelby can slam
in addition to racking up insane cs
advantages in lane
in lck 2019 spring he became the first
league competitor
ever to achieve 100 overall kda
and was handed an mvp award for his
trouble and what a way to end the game
skt gonna squeeze griffin here into the
dumpster
and they are going to do it skt
will sweep in the playoffs and take down
every single team in their path they are
the most dominant team from the korean
region
and they are the very accurate winners
of today
unfortunately chobe is also known for
something else
being metaphysically incapable of
securing himself a top spot
in any playoff ever in the six lck
playoffs in which he's competed
chobi has finished second in two of them
and third in
four of them and while he must be bound
to win
one sunday he can't help but feel for
the guy
taking the top spot on our list is none
other than the poster child of nadota
arteezy they're doing a lot of damage
always still alive though
it's beautiful look at these bounces
he's just wailing away on them oh my
god they've got white gg
considered one of the greatest
competitors ever to touch the game of
dota
this sad boy turned global superstar was
destined for greatness from the get-go
he proceeded to join evil geniuses took
top three at his first international
and well the team just fell off so he
left to join this new
super team secret whilst eg went on to
win the next international
then he rejoined eg but they fell off
again
so he rejoined secret finished almost
dead last at the international and after
that
while eg took third rejoined eg yet
again
and well you get where this is going i
can't start this interview without
asking this question how does it feel
like to return
um well it feels okay to be back in eg
uh actually this is hard to answer him
oh my god since then he spent almost
half a decade staying loyal to eg
trying to secure the one thing that over
the course of his eight-year career
he's never been able to achieve a win at
any
valve sponsored event despite
revolutionizing the mid lane and
accruing over
2.2 million dollars in prize winnings
alone
artesi has never managed to win a major
never mind a ti
in fact it took him seven years just to
make his first major final
which he lost three games to two the
crazy thing is that he made his next one
a year later which he also lost three
games or two
in get this a reverse sweep ouch
please for god's sake someone at least
give this kid a major
taken away by the mystic snake they have
to pop out they have to fight
at least he'll be able to get one die
back over on the tuscar or maybe he can
get more
a double kill for arteezy a triple kill
for art easy
he's just turned this crap up well there
we go guys
that was that did we miss out any other
ridiculously unlucky players on our list
if we did let me know in the comments
section thanks for watching
and i'll see you all in the next one
will he be able to secure the kill he
sees the tracers go
no scyther will win the fight he'll inch
his way on up geo's gonna be next in
line but this could be a tough shot
an empire could wrestle away the round
there's geo just waiting he doesn't pull
the trigger he sees it he pops up
oh no geo you gotta hit your shots young
will be the last one left
he was so important for faze he turns
his back he's got the pistol
but shepard will deny the comeback